okay for people joining this livestream
this is one of a series of meetings
about image audio and signal processing
features for the upcoming new version of
both language so where we got to last
time we passed all the image
functionality in the middle of audio yes
we stopped after voice tiles and the
discussion about entities okay and style
Pickers do we need to come back to that
or show me let's keep going on this list
and I think we might have to come back
to that separately is that correct I
guess we already have a meeting for that
next week okay I didn't see that yet but
okay fine all right where do we start
here how do you identify okay is that
running yes prototype builds okay so if
I like call for something that's going
to tell me what it is is that right that
one I haven't tested but things like
instruments speech those are the kinds
of categories about 500 categories we
can identify
whereas the pleasure
hot dogs not coming up that something's
coming up there so let's see oh boy
this notebook seems diseased something's
working ok so if I say audio capture
that one might still be broken you have
seen that earlier this weekend doesn't
work at all
no okay
but you can get many of the audio data
Masari example data audio
something deeps in the background might
have been something crashing here
this is not doesn't seem to be working
oh yes it is okay so if I say flute for
example audio flute and I say example
data of the flute why is it taking so
long oh did it just crash let's just
crash okay I can't run this but so
basically the idea is should I look at
audio identify in Docs yes
so you have a masking mechanism for do
just like four images is that right
what do you mean like four images image
identify doesn't have my skin no I
understand but here you've got a masking
option so what do you identify bright
this one we can say what parts of audio
to look into to identify to me to
identify could also have a masking I
suppose so yes I'm not sure if it's a
good idea
okay so I don't understand what this is
so this is it what is this is this the
various possibilities or why isn't it
like image identify where it's primarily
giving you one thing the data set that
we have used in this case is labeling
the same audio as multiple things and
that's why here as well in the result we
are thinking it's more correct to return
the multiple things the same thing about
image identify but image identify tries
to identify a single dominant thing in
the image
and I'm kind of imagining that here a
typical use case would be I mean I don't
get this because I think that the thing
I might also want is something which was
more like image contents where you're
generating like a time series where you
say this is a bird chirping type thing
I'm making sense yes I'm not buying this
particular thing there's no chance in
hell we're going to show this it's
excluded yeah okay fine okay but but I
don't really get this I mean in other
words what let's think about use cases
for tea or identify it's like you have
something and it's got a fairly small
loop and it's like there's a noise what
is it it's a dog barking its or whatever
right it's it's already been audio has
already been sort of shattered into
those pieces or alternatively you're
trying to tag just like you are with
image contents and things are trying to
tag pieces of audio with what they are
am i right parts of audio you mean right
yeah pieces of audio with what they are
now you're claiming that the pure play I
mean like image identify it's a
rhinoceros you know one can reasonably
expect that there are pictures of things
right so it makes sense to try and
identify a single object in it now with
audio you might make the claim which i
think is false that there's usually more
than one thing going on right but I
think that's not what this function is
about I think what this function is
supposed to be about presumably I mean
it's not consistent I mean if you have a
rhinoceros and an elephant in a picture
image identify it's gonna say one or the
other I'm making sense
right image identify says gives one
results by default yes right so audio
identify has to have the same behavior
in my view now maybe it's not a useful
function tab maybe the useful function
is something which tags audio and events
in time series with which parts of it
are bird chirping which parts with a dog
bark I don't think it's useful to use
time serious with of entities because
what vector space can you operate on
entities
the values are vector spaces but we have
annotations so you could say over this
this time segment there is a dog barking
yes yes yes yes yeah
on on one second
I mean it seems pretty random that for
an image of the lots of things that I
you know it just picks out one thing
this one could it be equally random you
know and there is one that gets more
things right image cases or yeah that's
right it also is because there's an
algorithm you know look the dominant
image thing what is this a picture of
that is a fairly common question right
what is this sound'
is a less common question except I could
run into all these background sounds
from from these phone calls what is it
it's somebody you know eating a
watermelon no I'm just joking but you
know in num that's the question
image identify its what is this thing
what do you identify will be what is
that sound
yeah if you want that level of
consistency then then we force this one
to return a single I think so yeah I
think so are you so what is this sound
they don't know what the technical
limitations are from that because in in
we could really post process and just
get the highest probability
identification out but I guess the
longest time I mean if what you hear is
okay so if you hear a screech of tires
and then you hear shattering glass what
do you say I mean this is just the wrong
function I mean and the right function
is the thing that gives the tag time
series it's not just having multiple
identifications at different times you
may as well have just a wind as the
background noise all the time and then
the dog barking all the time and what
what does it return then both of them if
if you have you know if you had a
standard but you could also have the
dogs barking for for three minutes it's
a dog barking okay and then there's a
little bird tweet for you know one
second does it mention the bird tweet or
not
this one audio identify is not designed
to know it actually samples the whole
audio so even if your audio is very long
it's just samples so audio we don't have
a good sense about what portion of the
audio was covered by identification one
or two
I'm confused so in other words you say
it's just something so I might miss the
bird tweet or it might miss the the key
thing I mean it like might be like come
you know you've got an audio and it's
nothing much is happening it's just
rustling and so on and then suddenly
there's a gunshot for example and what
you care about is that I think that this
thing of annotating the whole thing with
what's going on when yes the analog for
images of annotating the image with
little rectangle and says what is in the
different parts of an image right for
which but we have a mechanism namely
time series which is a from which we
could extract I mean you know the what
I'm saying is that that's not going to
be a useful time series because how are
you going to interpolate between
entities how you gonna operate on
entities as if they're in a vector space
so you're thinking of some some weaker
form of time series which you're saying
the the thing we don't have is sort of a
categorical time series whereas at this
time this is what was happening yeah
saying we have a time series where where
the values of are in some vector space
yes
you know the whole framework assumes
that you can operate on them as if there
are a vector space
I think we've encountered this issue in
other places too right but it's a what
I'm saying is that there's a it needs
it's a much weaker form of time it's not
I'm not saying it's not yes but it's a
much weaker form a time series I mean
how would you low-pass filter those
entities yeah yeah it doesn't make any
sense let me ask my this question
timeline plot okay it deals with what
you might call a weak time series - you
know you'll it's even you know more
general because it deals with both um
you know events and intervals right
changes no I understand but that's
that's basically what we want for audio
identify we want to know this was the
interval where the dog was barking
this was the interval where the whale
was was what was but what do you want to
do with the stuff that comes out which
is not a time series it's something okay
so I think a typical thing you want to
do is you want to say how many times did
the dog bark show me a plot of the
average time between box it's really
gonna be eventually all your contents so
all you identify I think we should
assume we have a consistent
identification thing happening all
across the audio so the thing is
intended to work on a small piece of
audio where you say what is that weird
noise mm-hmm kind of like a mature
identify is attended to work on a small
piece of image where there's one yeah
well that's one thing that's going on
yeah so I think that those would be the
analogs yeah we have something else that
I think is very useful not only for this
but for a variety of things which is a
thing that's later in this review which
is called audio annotations I see that
yeah okay and and so for instance
you know if you want the song lyrics or
you want the notes or you want the text
yeah you know from speech to text or you
want the speaker's the speakers or you
want a variety of other you know more
technical information to you know which
is very common in linguistics and other
areas
then you can have those as annotations
and that's in fact a common thing to do
to annotate up or well so that's gonna
raise the question what about audio of
what about image and annotation which we
don't have right so we're looking at
that too I think that that would be
extremely useful in medical image
processing daikon format it's all about
the annotations that's the whole goddamn
workflow the actual core image is sort
of a you know yes it's important but
it's you know the doctors markup you
know you can annotate and and that's
happening you know what's interesting
about annotation and maybe you're going
to come to this in audio annotation is
that not only do you want the you know
something like textual annotation you
also might want to annotate a region for
instance exactly exactly yeah okay um
well happens in all you as well you may
want to annotate a single time that some
event happens yeah so we have both okay
fine but so then ultimately what you're
saying is the audio contents will return
some annotated audio it could because
there we have sort of them processing
flows out turned out they can you know
among other things we want to be able to
convert those into more that can be
processed in a variety of ways
throughout the system yo I understand I
understand sir okay but but then ok so
audio identify the plan would be it's a
small for its intended for small
fragments of audio where the question is
what is that noise just as immature
identify yes
yeah which is fine fine and you know for
example it should be able to tell you
that's the bird call of the
such-and-such kind of bird right but I
think it's 500 categories at this point
right so it's not as where it's image
identifies 5,000 so it's it's a vector
it's an order of magnitude
smaller 10,000 I think I think 10 5,000
whatever the so for example you know we
did have from several years ago that
that project that birdsong
identification thing which turned into
the bird AI app it might see worth that
that's done by Joffrey and Andres group
do you want to track him down
we've looked at various more specialized
areas which this one isn't okay this one
is a general-purpose yeah I understand
okay so that's a that's a bit potential
build-out and you have a hierarchical
you know I want you to be able to pick
out that this is a 2012 Ferrari no I'm
sure you know there's a very with it
with a loose something or other right
you can go infinitely deep in this stuff
yeah right but okay but that is a 1959
Gibson the you know okay so there's a
specificity goal I mean look what we've
done in the case of let's be clear in
the case of audio image identify we are
dealing with picture above common nouns
right so that does not include things
which are not described by essentially a
single you know now unlike thing in
English right so I mean it could be a
multi-word thing but it's basically a
noun construct and it's not something
where there are serious adjectives added
on to it and I think you know for
example you know a bunch of species that
would be the case but it's not like it's
a a two-year-old such and such kind of
bird as opposed to just that generic
bird but I think it would be worth in
the case of the I mean I don't know
whether there are data sets for all
these things but okay so that's a that's
a direction to expand then after so you
said they're 500 um sound types that
this word this is currently dealing with
Bernal okay alright let's just have a
little look at the other um what is the
sound energy object Oh a sound entity
object
wait a minute a concrete entity object
oh that's the I see that's the different
okay does that mean okay when there is a
balk is this thing trying to return dog
or is it trying to return dog bark the
dog sound or dog bark the sound entity
and as you see the entity object is
future eyes I don't know where we're
gonna be going with that I think it
makes sense more to have sound entity
objects return as opposed to as opposed
to the generator entity that is so in
other words you know in okay so that's a
little tricky because you know if we
know the generator for example a dog
bark is made by a dog if we have that
mapping which we certainly could have
from the sound entity right we certainly
could have one of the properties of that
be its generator mm-hmm same thing
should happen for concept entities and
entities whose concepts are coming back
from image identify and we don't have
proper linking between those and
generate or entities yeah so maybe we
should okay so that's an issue for the
content curation folk that doesn't sound
so difficult if that's the way we do it
I mean then what you're telling me is
that you know then for the bird songs
it's a you know cockatiel sound is an
entity distinct from the cockatiel him
itself right yes okay okay
understand I think we're going to need
those generator things for the sounds
maybe you can try and get those into
curation okay they should be pretty
straightforward I mean that you know but
it clearly some things will not have for
example you know squealing tires it's
not clear we don't probably have a
generator entity for that you know I
don't think we want to return we might
have a concept entity like car for
example okay so there are different
kinds of entities there they're the boy
what a mess what a messy thing all right
this is this is something for our I'm
trying to unscramble alright let's just
look at this function some more so it's
it's mirroring image identify otherwise
oh great I guess really do I hate that
way of by the way writing out the the
mixed caps version we should avoid that
we should just call it quotes class in
the docs here no lower case yeah we just
should avoid that kind of notation
because we're not you know we don't
usually use it right there are only a
few places I recall we have that but
sure I could change that um there's
questions on a live stream would there
be a way to cluster a longer audio clip
into chunks absolutely we're working on
that um yeah
yeah we're absolutely working on this
this is what yeah so in audio equivalent
for Yolo used to create bounding boxes
yeah we we absolutely do have in the EM
the neural net repository that you can
find online we absolutely have Yolo
networks and so on and we're absolutely
using that for image cases the I don't
actually know how the audio scanning
stuff works does it use a yellow type
algorithm or something else when you're
scanning for what are the different
elements in this one of the different
kinds of sounds in this audio stream
what does it use do you know we don't
have it right the audio contents you're
talking about yes
we don't have that yet there are there
are networks proposed for that it's on
earth okay fine fine have it but yeah we
don't do they work the same way as the
yellow networks for Images or do they
work some different way cuz one
dimensional I think it's a different way
I have to look closely compared okay
okay onward
all right audio instance q is this a dog
bark that's basically what that's asking
right yes seems reasonable I mean I
suspect if we can have these generator
entity things it's like you know is this
an elephant rather than having to ask is
the Snell ephant sound I mean it should
support the generators as well as the
sounds themselves right okay let's see
net encoder what did you have to add and
do we need to look at we're not talking
about image contents at this time right
no no image contents yet so is this a is
this a thing you've marked up the the
window function or this window function
here if you go to the audio net encoders
it's a net encoder that's really weird
rocks but ya know but I'm just wondering
why in the file name oh I see it's part
of net encoders um you know that that's
something we might mention to Brian that
it will be useful when you see a page
like this this looks for all the world
like a rough page and it should have
some striped at the top here maybe it's
in the categorization
yeah entity type Nats encoder that
should be more visible on this page
could you mention that to Brian right
sure and I'm assuming you want that for
all other special types of pages yes yes
okay so I'm not seeing the window thing
here it's basically just yeah I just
checked with Carlo we haven't he hasn't
updated it I progress the part it's just
gonna be one of those other string
parameters for sounds reasonable feature
extracts okay great so right now we're
using audio identify to extract features
by default so it's a great improvement
there you can also see it in features
Facebook that same thing okay yeah
sounds good okay features Facebook there
is one example in the ref page for audio
we have some special labeling for audio
that is allowing us to also play the
audio objects or the all Europe oh my
gosh we went donkus over here what the
heck is this so it's a spectrogram
with a play button yes the design look
at that yes yep okay we've gone through
several iterations I don't know if this
is the latest but we've been toning down
for a while there to play button
dominated everything you couldn't see
things it's been yeah I mean it needs to
be nice and transparent exactly that's
that's spectrogram is strangely
different from the way that you I mean
in other words you could when you have
an audio object display the spectrogram
immediately I mean as it is right now
and I'm not sure I'm wild about it
you know if I do you know your generic
you know if I do a generic audio capture
assuming my microphone is picking
anything up hello ello ello okay so
that's all I see there and there's no
easy way I mean the only way to get the
spectrogram is to literally ask for the
spectrogram if you hover over that audio
label in front of the file you see the
waveform if the audio is very long you
see a child waveform I didn't know that
well you learn something new every day I
certainly didn't know that that showed
the waveform okay hmm
interesting so if I show if I say show
that it's actually not showing the
waveform it's just showing this but if
you start playing then it's going to
dynamically show you the waveform or if
you click on it it's going to show you
the so explain to me why we should show
spectrograms rather than the waveforms
here generally has more information well
I agree well fair enough
yeah sure okay it bothers me slightly
that you know if that's the case why
aren't we showing spectrograms for the
you know for generic audio in that
expanded view if you click on that
viewer in the middle it's gonna or maybe
double click on that it's gonna okay
yeah now now start playing again it's
gonna show you shortly I had no idea
I've never seen this before how would I
possibly discover that feature pretty
much sure we have shown this to you but
I agree it's not intuitive - it's
absolutely undiscoverable if I you
double click on the middle of that thing
to get it to start showing you like a
you know like a stereo you know thingy
is like like how would one ever discover
that I mean if we're going to do
something like that we got to have some
notifier that says that the first time
people look at this or some right maybe
at least a tooltip that that would be
the very easy way to do it but I know
why not I mean a tooltip seems like a I
mean that's the tooltip down there are
you gonna do something here I mean I'm
not sure anybody's gonna mouse over this
area why would they do it why is there
anything in that CC here's the point to
induce the mouse over if you say
something like greater than greater than
or dot or something like that it kind of
induces a mouse over because it's
suggesting there's something else there
but this I would never have thought to
mouse over it because it's like well
it's just some random UUID why would I
mouse over it
am I making sense yes
they um yeah so okay I think this needs
some work I mean what could we do here
that would just give it a hint it needs
some kind of hint that there's something
to see here I think that's a why don't
we ask the design folk to suggest
something here a reasonable sweep I
don't think let's not get this now
because I'm guessing other than the
tooltip you're thinking about some
little icon over there somewhere yeah
something that would cause you don't
want to roll over the thing ever because
otherwise I'm just like that's a dead
piece of material I don't want to roll
over it at all right how do I get out a
full if I say audio plot of percent
three then I will get the traditional
waveform type thing yes yes um and how
do I get that like stereo thingy thing
or is that not or is that only something
that makes sense instantaneously you
know the frequency bands picture only
makes sense instantaneously I think
right
okay let's keep going so it's alright
I'm okay with using for the for the
features based plot
I guess I'm okay with using these some
spectrogram icons I think it's I think
it doesn't make sense to use I think
it's as you say it's more informative
for feature space you know it'll be like
vowels or something and you'll you'll
see different spectrograms
for different vowels and you wouldn't
really see anything different in the UM
weight in the waveform right okay let's
go on audio stream current audio what is
that doing
do we have an ADD current audio we don't
have a current audio function yet do we
we don't know for now this is this is a
soft release of Karen all you I guess we
are having it property to all your
stream objects that is taking the called
Karen audio which is returning the
current buffer of the audio that is
being played by or captured from the
device and then you can do the same
dynamic of audio stream Karen audio to
do similar things as you would do with
dynamic of Karen image so what is the
typical buffer length um
4,000 or something like that I think we
have it summer so it's like one tenth of
a second if it's fine to 4 kilohertz on
play night okay so and how would one
actually use this this will be something
like what's feeding it in progressively
to a neural net or something we could do
that right sure that would be we have a
mechanism for that quite to feed it into
some kind of sequence space neuron that
I mean right now we're primarily in in
speech recognizer we're primarily taking
a whole clump you know of audio and
looking at the whole thing
right right but we could do things like
you know if you're looking at longer
chunks you could do I do even all you
identify at that chunk maybe for now
more interestingly would be something
like give me loudness oh so you can show
or for example you could do that
spectrogram I mean that that whatever
the name what is the name of the plot
that makes the that thing that shows you
know activity in different bands
equalizer I mean how do we make one of
those can I do that from this from that
audio how do I make an equaliser picture
don't know if we have a so that's
relevant if we if we've got a current
audio instantaneous type thing right
it's not relevant in here
okay so audio plot doesn't support that
directly right no no this is just a
waveform plot okay
but I guess Roger we did think about
having this more generic as well we did
you it's not obvious that that should
all be an audio plot I mean if that's a
because obviously the dynamic current
audio I mean what one would expect is
you know dynamic audio equalizer plot
you know dynamic of audio equalizer plot
of current audio and that would then
show you that thing bouncing around on
the screen that make sense yes equalizer
it's not quite the right name it's it's
it's really a sort of the amount of
energy in each frequency band the
equalizer would you would said I mean
it's like the instantaneous it's the
spectrum as opposed to the spectrum
right like audio spectrum plot okay all
right let's move on um well it's time
for a streaming what does that mean I
mean that what do you mean by that it's
just one of the format's we didn't have
streaming for so audio out of court you
couldn't support them for a until we
added this I see okay
and then it like m4b is another
extension for m4a audio books use it
there was its and some of them are very
long so it's important to have it mm-hmm
yeah what the string that's extremely
well my person yeah right let's like
streaming out might be I should read it
and the version of the N Cass book I
wonder how long that will be
I'm probably more than 12 hours and see
I have a lot of mine to figure it out
but let me not um actually I'm just
curious I'm sorry I'm gonna let me
satisfy my curiosity here so let's see I
think in the color phone or so many
words there were uh five hundred eighty
three thousand words so here probably if
I say five eight three thousand words
for lucky six to five
of speaking great I've had a couple of
audiobooks to during the 20 in the
mid-20s or 20 hours those look good look
at how accurate this is the book is
actually 1,200 pages long
look at how accurate that is for single
size document well though it thinks the
book will be shorter there okay it had a
lot of pictures okay
all right anyway so that's 65 hours boy
I'm not I'm not gonna do the audiobook
version of that in a hurry um okay
onward
what do you block map done so what is
that that's the analog a block map for
an audio function right we've had that
before we just had the function version
of it so the function argument could
only take actual functions now we're
adding some predefined string functions
like what see those hash sorry yeah
we're adding instead of argument and
we're adding those are named arguments I
see um that isn't correct a spot that
says portion rather than partition
location okay I'll fix that
um bet I have some confidence in dq8 we
should get it correct but I'm so close
why is the spell checker not running on
that thing that seems like a more
systematic bug maybe there's some bug in
tentative cells not running the spell
checker you might want to show that to
Brian sure okay so these are so what
does it do by defy default operates on
raw data can work on other forms of the
partition so I don't understand how you
tell it that it's going to be given I
mean that means it's being given an
association right
you can say so F could be something like
max of slot audio data or max of slot
for you data um and then in the second
case
each partition is converted to the
forest going through Fourier transform
and then that data gets passed to the
function sorry sorry sorry I spaced for
one second could you say it again I'm
saying the function f now could be
something like max of max of hash is
basically max of hash of audio - audio
data but you can also say something like
max of hash for you data and then you
just send the partition through for you
and then send it to structurally when we
do something like this normally and by
the way this isn't how we normally
document and you know elements of an
association here we'd normally say just
F is given the association with keys
blah blah blah I don't think we are
actually in the code creating an
association you you may not understand
so this is very similar to what happens
in clouds submit for example where
there's a callback function right
exactly and so what we do there right as
we generate we say what keys are going
to be used all right so we specify which
might be convenient here as well right
we're specifying like in this case we
would say but what we've an example that
would be cloud submit for instance you
can give there we go the following
events no no no this is though handler
functions keys right those are
that is the list of things that you can
tell it are going to be fed to the
handler functions right but those are
really the string keys of that
association right yes that's right but
that means that you get to have the
handler function say F of hash tasks and
so on nicely okay so this is more
analogous to what happens in the mail
like for example if I say mail receiver
function okay okay so here I don't
actually know how this works it derives
an association here but I don't know
whether it actually gets the whole
Association or whether it's some kind of
lazy process do you get what I'm saying
yeah I hope it's lazy right because you
may need all attachments and stuff if
you could ask for him how that works but
this is the documentation pattern and
this is I think the usage pattern for
something like this okay I mean what
you're doing here is you're saying
you're changing the functionality
basically because the single hash you
just want to say is the raw audio object
correct but it's this hash Fourier is
something different so I'm a little bit
and I think I got that from one of the
time series functionality that they're
documenting the arguments of the
function f like that
Roger your number which my leaving Matt
moving that probably
um sorry what are you saying you you you
Oh huh I don't think I've ever seen this
well I'm sure I have hmm
this kind of needs some consistency
discussion I'm not thrilled here I mean
I don't understand how it can access
both of these right I mean if you take
well how does it work if you take an
association you say hash three it's not
going to get that element of the
Association right if I say association a
arrow you know B arrow bah blah blah and
I do and then I say I have a function
here that says you know hash to amperes
and of that yeah just like that
that's yeah whereas if I say hash B
it'll come out like that I don't like
this very much what are we going to do
with this I mean there's exactly what we
solve with the handler function keys for
these other functions now guess
something like moving map Roger I don't
know the full history but maybe the
numbered arguments were introduced first
I mean this predates the thing of seeing
it as an association is I mean as a
compatibility bridge one could do things
where there's some weird method function
that determines whether the thing will
automatically look to see which one of
these it is and whether or generate an
association or list which is basically
what you're talking about here mm-hmm I
mean it's not a beautiful solution but I
think I think it's got to be
consistently an association or
consistently a list and I think in many
of these an association is good but as I
said the documentation isn't right here
it should be more like the male receiver
function documentation because there are
many different ways you could
potentially use the Association I mean
you could say you know you could use
values on the Association and just
extract all the values or a whole
variety of things that are operating
just on the whole sort of Association
together yeah I'm not sure we even had a
super well you working association at
the time we did that function well fair
enough but I'm saying maybe we need to
you know we can have a compatibility
bridge but maybe we need to move to the
preferred form being the Association one
sure so I mean if you need to let's get
a meeting that involves particularly
Fahim who worked on the male stuff and
on some of these callback functions to
go through the general way to do this
does that sound reasonable otherwise I
would just you know expect to feed these
things in association with a possible
compatibility bridge are you happy with
that
it's generated no I'm saying you feed
this you know you feed the function f an
association of these things oh I see
as long as we can do it lazily so that
as you said not everything is computed
right well that's a question that we
have to ask for him I don't know how
what the infrastructure for that is okay
so can you ask him and we can get back
to this in a subsequent meeting sure
let's try to move through this right now
so Web Audio search what on earth is
that really going to do because not such
a okay so this is keyword based Web
Audio search is that right yes boy oh
boy oh boy that's very weird what
start doing those are the well you can
specify what properties you wanna get
back for example a very typical cases
web image search and then quotes
thumbnails which will just give you a
list of thumbnails and I think here you
should have a an analogue of thumbnails
that's probably something which is just
a sampling of the audio I mean in a
perfect world one would have a trimming
function for audio analogous to the
thing the auto trimming that we're
trying to do for images where you're
trimming to a point of interest mm-hmm
and you know in the thumbnailing here
obviously you know the physical size
doesn't cut it for audio but maybe
there's some way I mean if we had auto
trimming we could trim out like the
thumbnail of the audio is a few second
piece of audio did that make any sense
man I don't know
boy I'm now revealing my hopelessness
that you know like when you when you
sample audio from a typical music site
they'll give you little pieces of songs
right those little pieces of what 15
seconds long or something mm-hmm 15 30
okay but so maybe the thing to do is the
a log of thumbnails is something like
that sample which is always from the
beginning or not always from the
beginning typically not from the
beginning because typically the
beginning is boring in some way right
okay so fine so so there is an auto
trimming that's going on there and if we
could do that same kind of auto trimming
to find the interest in 15 seconds then
that is one definite thing we want to
return here making sense free sound is
all free that free sound and SoundCloud
are the two services we are trying to
connect to SoundCloud is a bit more
tricky users can specify copyright and
things like that a lot of the tracks are
not even downloadable most of them
should be streamable but for that
to finish our round of proper URL
streaming so that really we just get a
chunk play get rid of it but so what's
the analog of fair use for you know
showing thumbnails for sounds and I know
there's a history of this it's gotten
complicated right
I mean does SoundCloud allow you to have
you know allow you a way to essentially
extract a thumbnail of the sound I don't
have to look into it it that may also
differ based on the copyright that the
user specifies okay I mean the correct
thing in my opinion for this would be
just like you have those spectrograms
in the case of the feature space plots I
think there is a useful thing to do here
well I don't really know I mean the the
thing mom wants what is the right thing
here I mean the typical thing is going
to be I I'm not sure what we talk to me
about use cases for this Web Audio
search so I think that over time we'll
have more services mm-hmm
and the question is this is gonna split
you know so free sound is has kind of
like crushed glass female screams dog
barks all those kinds of things but you
might use as you know various sound
effects what a sound effects so that's
that kind of interest you know it's
almost like an icon like an illustration
like something yeah clip art yes clip
art for sound kind of sound cloud is
more like musicians publishing and it's
becoming kind of like a publishing
platform but they're they're pivoting
all the time so it's hard to say exactly
what they're doing
in order to make it you know viable but
it started out that way I described it
okay but so what do we expect people to
do with that here I mean you know some
people are going to do random machine
you know I want to generate a Mozart bot
and I want to have a bunch of sampled
Mozart performances and things right yes
I think you can use it in a variety of
ways let's say that you wanted to have
an auto scoring function mm-hmm you know
to create the score from it or something
that gets the text or just the actual
illustration you know I understand how
you're gonna get it you know I just want
five seconds of a Bach fugue right but
then I mean one day well sure nobody's I
mean with with image search you can feed
an image and search for something which
has some vague match to that image is
there an analogous thing with sound I
don't think people are going to care
about that I'd yeah there's services for
that right like Shazam is you just true
why it'll tell you what it is right um
yeah it's a different thing I mean given
this aprox it's the same time you can
search with that right once you know
what it is yes for sure it's effectively
solving that problem right okay but
anyway back to this what is the sample
piece of this doing if you click on it
this is that does that work is that tiny
I it should work it should be just a
sample audio that is provided by free
sound typically if it's shorter than
anything but then okay so I understand
why the duration second argument
generated this output so title is always
there I'm I think sample is always there
so duration was something that got add I
don't think we should do it that way
look at how webinar search works okay no
I agree that things and then I'm
assuming you want more of a flat list
result rather than data set results I
mean the default is the data set for
Weber image search
but the case that I seem to use most of
the time is web image search comma
thumbnails I see okay what do you
annotate do you have something for this
here yes oh boy okay so this has some
structure wrapped around audio that's
kind of like masking but it's
annotations is that right it's it's a
type of meta information that you that's
intended to be processed you know it's
like properties in graphs the things
that it's it's sort of in addition I
think it helps if you actually go up
that list rather than going down the
list annotations is a new symbol we are
proposing as an option as a new option
that can go to audio for now and then
image time series whatever else later we
already have that function called
annotation right yes which this is
nothing to do with or is it no it's
doing nothing with it it's just that it
was taken so we made it prove plural no
we really thought about
there's something else but annotation
seems to be the very correct that's what
we call it we should probably you know
plan to migrate this function I agree
that your that your use of annotation
seems good which suggests to me that we
should gradually retire this use so we
so we document this one as something
else
and although annotation singular will
still work you know we won't plan to
promote it okay that makes sense I mean
I don't know what you know what is the
difference what is mouse annotation the
heck is this
so annotation column Mouse okay so so
this annotation is basically providing a
current value that can be picked up by
dynamic when something is in focus right
yes okay I deeply running out of time
right now but I think what we need to do
here I think what we should plan on is
renaming this to something like I mean
because we've already got things like
mouse annotation which is already quite
quite weird I mean we should have a
discussion with John Fultz and try and
see what we can do with them because I
think this function has been less
successful than we might like it's been
with us 11 years now
it's you know I think it grabbed to
bigger thing um but it's easy to do the
compatibility bridge I mean there's not
not a big problem with that
um that's let's get a meeting about this
please with John can can you do that
yeah no I'll send a request for okay
okay now annotations is the option
annotation value is the one that can
save and get values for that option all
you annotate eventually image annotate
and so forth is that all gonna be
functions that are generating with the
higher level functions and objectives
annotations for the object right right I
think that's interesting I mean so
that's an automated so audio image
annotate would be the analog of image
contents but it sprays information into
the image object right and then the
returned display just like you're saying
audio plot will support annotations so
would image basically support
annotations the default of appearance of
an image that has been annotated needs
to have annotations on the image
patient's but in the case of image I
don't know whether it should display
them by default that's different issue
maybe the attached cell could allow the
annotations to be switched on or off
sure but here there's always got to be
by hand annotations that you support for
example you know just mark this
particular interval as blah blah blah so
how would you do that here
so parent the annotation value can take
an association you can actually type it
in so I want from time 1 to 2 mark it as
speaker 1 mark time 3 to 4 mark that
speaker 2
we we don't currently have any
interactive way of injecting annotations
into audio but that could be another way
well this is wild this is really wild in
my opinion this is an l-value
what the heck is going on here what is
the semantics of this it's just an
l-value but what's an l-value
the whole annotation value thing is an
l-value know the so that one thing
that's absolutely key is that those
annotations go with the audio and they
don't live somewhere else because then
they don't survive a session another
understand that so they should be I mean
but normally the way these things work
is you put you know it's like you know
show with graphics or something right
you you change some aspects of the
graphics but most of the actual data is
you know internally it's just a pointer
you know but there is a separate
expression that is the one which has had
the new annotation done yeah so that's
what we want to avoid what because then
you have for bulk you know you really
don't want to copy if you know I know
but this is not a copy that's the whole
point
Roger it's not a copy the core thing in
that case with show the core data is not
a copy right it's only the wrapper
that's has to be copied and I think the
same should be done here that is the
core audio thing is not gonna get copied
somehow it is just and I'm not saying
necessarily how to do it but what what
happens is you know like there's a core
image that might be ten megabytes or
something right but it is merely the
wrapping around it that some kind of
outer image wrapper not the core numeric
array or whatever it is that actually is
the image the raw array that is the
image would never be copied but these
this live of out of core you know okay
well okay well but that the rapper does
not have to live out of core the rapper
is its own so you're saying it lives out
of course oh great so it has a UUID
basically and the thing the thing with
the rapper can point to the thing with
the same UUID by making sense i guess
that you know well four out of core the
problem is less severe right because
even the copy is not as expensive if
you're you're never gonna copy it
because it's just gonna point the big
blob of data is at some UUID out of core
right right right so what I'm saying is
the annotations should be a thin layer
that could be copied if they had to be
you know parts of them could be Copic is
not a big deal because they're just a
thin layer just like any other
expression where you will you say append
to this list and so on certain things
get copy and others don't
I there's no way we should do a thing
where you have an L value that is you
know it's it's just not well anyway okay
listen I have to go um we'll have to
continue this because there's several
loose ends here um there's a lot of
lovely functionality and some loose ends
so to be continued I guess some I guess
next week um okay but can you take a
think about this idea of a wrapper
mechanism for doing these annotations
please sure and see where we can go with
that okay all right I will see y'all
soon and thanks to folks on the
livestream okay okay see you later bye
bye honey